TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And you're watching
"The Developer Show."
This is a very special
episode, because it's
the 100th time we've
brought you an update
about the coolest
developer news from Google.
To celebrate, I've asked some
of our friends to help out.
The Accelerated Mobile
Pages, or AMP story format,
provides you with a
mobile-focused format
for delivering news and
information as visually
rich tap-through stories.
To get started, head on
over to the post for links
to a tutorial and documentation.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
AMP for email is also
now available for emails
to be formatted and sent
as AMP documents.
As a part of this, we're kicking
off the Gmail developer preview
of AMP for email.
So once you've
built your emails,
you'll be able to
test them using Gmail.
Take a look at the post for
code and a link to the spec.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
Starting today,
the API for purchases.products
will return promo
as a new value for the
field purchase type
when the user
redeems a promo code.
This improvement to the
Google Play Developer API
makes it easier to
track your promotions
from your own Beckett.
For more details and links to
the docs, check out the post.
DAN GALPIN: Go 1.10
is now available.
It includes automatic
caching of build and test
results as well as hundreds
of other smaller changes.
Links to the release notes
and the download page
are on the post.
JEN PERSON: You can now
integrate your server side
applications with the Firebase
Cloud Messaging v1 API
using the Firebase
Admin SDKs, which
allow you to send messages and
manage topic subscriptions.
Check out the post for some
code and links to the docs.
ROTO MEIER: Compute engine
machine talks with 96 vCPUs
and up to 624
gigabytes of memory
are now generally available.
For applications that
can scale vertically,
you can leverage all
96 vCPUs to decrease
the number of VMs needed to run
your applications while still
reducing your total
cost of ownership.
Take a look at the
post for more details.
If you're wondering if you're
prepared for your Professional
Data Engineer
Certification exam,
well, Google Cloud Certified now
offers an online practice exam.
We designed it to help
you familiarize yourself
with the type of questions
that will be asked
and check your readiness.
More details and a
link are on the post.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Please remember
to like, subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And on behalf of all of us
on "The Developer Show" team,
thank you for watching.
We'll see you next week.
From the vantage point of not
being able to see anything--